[Music]
hey what's up
mkbhd here okay so now that's december
we're
rounding out the year the annual
smartphone awards are coming up so i got
to make sure i've seen like every
smartphone
that's come out during the year 2020. so
one of the last ones to come across my
desk
is this guy this is the royal flex pie
2. now every year i have a couple
categories for those awards
one of them is the bust of the year for
the worst smartphone that comes out
and the first flex pi was a candidate
for that but i
also always have a most improved
category
and believe it or not this flex pi 2
just based on my usage of it so far and
what i've seen
is actually a candidate for the most
improved award
that being said i would still never
recommend
this in fact playing with this phone led
me to the logical conclusion
that among all of the alternate form
factor stuff we've seen
lately by alternate form factor i mean
not like a regular phone
but the swiveling ones and the folding
and the flipping and the rollables and
all that stuff
among all of these new alternate form
factors
this folding out screen version
as cool as it can look is not the way to
go
this phone this flex pi 2 had to change
a lot
to get to this point they sharpened a
lot of the previously rounded edges
they added a camera so now there's an
ultra wide standard and a telephoto
they've combined the power button and
fingerprint reader from the old flex pi
into one button like we see on many
other phones they've also added a much
larger earpiece at the top for phone
calls on both sides
where the last one just had tiny slots
they also added speakers to the top
and the bottom instead of just the top
so now it can create a stereo image
no matter what orientation it's in and
they've improved a lot of rotational
responsiveness
and stuff in the software so flipping
the phone over to use either side
isn't quite as unreliable as before and
then they've completely reworked
this hinge and the pieces around it to
dramatically improve it
so the old hinge cover was pretty rough
it had this rubber material that creaked
and
folded and you could literally feel
parts of the underlying hinge through it
this new one is massively different it's
this intricate weave of
metal teeth now so from the back from
the top and the bottom you can see
how everything fits together as you fold
it it all
folds and slides into place nicely and
it's actually
now folding completely flat in this
satisfying clap then there's some strong
magnets holding the two sides together
and you'll even notice the two sides are
thinner and the whole package is thinner
and lighter and more well-built more
refined
and feels more quality and yet after all
of that
opening this phone sounds like this
i mean closing it still fine but
i don't i feel like it shouldn't sound
like that like it just doesn't feel
correct i don't know maybe it needs
maybe it needs to warm up over time
because i do have the original flex pi
here
and this one used to make more noise but
now
now it doesn't actually make as much
creaking so maybe if you use it enough
eventually this one will
stop making so much noise as you open
and close it
but i don't know um also two flex buys
in the same room that's probably pretty
rare
weird flex but okay but it's not even
about this rough hinge look
like i said at the beginning it just
doesn't feel like the tech is anywhere
near ready for the specific
style of outside folding screen so
as we know there's a couple different
versions of foldable phones
the big fold the smaller clamshell
vertical fold
a lot of them have really interesting
promise but they all have one thing in
common
which is that they fold in and they
protect
that soft delicate foldable display
on the inside of something when you do
this fold on the outside
like this not only is it obviously not
protecting any of this precious screen
anymore
but it's also the most difficult to make
it look
good because you can't hide any tricks
or anything anywhere
everything is always exposed on the
outside like you might remember
motorola's trick with the razor which is
tucking the display into the chin when
it folds
shut to avoid a really tight crease when
folding it flat
or all of samsung's tricks the brushes
and the loop to fold it inside to avoid
a crease
in their version of a hinge but with the
flex pi folding out like this there's no
place to do much hiding of any tricks
the phone stretched over this hinge on
the outside when you're closed
and when you're using it it's open fully
flat when you're using both sides
it's just the most difficult version
technically speaking to get
right so on one hand i do want to
applaud royal for trying and
and giving us this much improved second
version but on the other hand
it seems like now with this massively
improved version and this
still being the experience you get and
it's still
being unprotected and very vulnerable it
seems like
it's time to stop is that crazy like i
want them
to keep working on hard ideas like this
but i feel like
we're learning our lesson and the fact
that alternate form factors are evolving
so much is showing us that there's other
better possibilities with the folding
display tech like it's crazy it's a very
2020 conversation which isn't can we
make folding phones work anymore
now it's it's more of which version of a
folding phone is the best way to do it
that's the new question but here is a
little thought i'll leave you with
and in my exploration of like every
phone that's come out this year
uh i've had to try a lot of not so great
phones so you don't have to
but uh in the press release for the
flexpi 2
in the press release for this phone they
compare this new
thing they've built with the thinner
sides
to the wings of a cicada it's right here
i'll link it below if i can find an
online version of it
but they compare it directly to cicada
wings and while at first that's kind of
an odd choice of a comparison to make
i think it's actually perfect maybe
accidentally perfect
so hear me out so first of all yeah they
picked the cicada because
it's actually a very well-liked animal
in china almost like a lucky animal
but okay fun nature fact cicada's wings
actually have a natural super
hydrophobic
protection layer over them like a bunch
of tiny
wax nanopillars is what i call them
they're one of the strangest wings in
nature
but they work really well so water
droplets when it rains
roll right off of them and actually when
they get dirty when dirt gets onto them
water coalesces and because of surface
tension basically grabs the dirt and
just rolls right off the top it's like a
natural
self-cleaning process and then on top of
that those
wings and that hydrophobic coating are
the only biomaterial
on planet earth known to kill bacteria
so the way it works
is i promise there's a point to this but
basically all those little hairs are are
so small and so close together
that water droplets that form on them
aren't small enough
to fall through them so they just roll
right across the top and glide off the
surface
and that's also true about bacteria
bacteria aren't
small enough to get through all those
little nano
pillars and they're actually sharp
enough that a bacteria's
outside membrane will be punctured by
them and it'll just fall apart
and die so all of that like
protection on top of a cicada wing that
naturally occurs
is like a protection layer that you just
don't see anywhere else in nature so in
other words
the cicadas wing is super thin
and light but it has a super high tech
protection
built in and the royal flex pie
doesn't and that's what it needs that's
that's that
extra layer of protection that something
like this outside folding
screen tech actually needs to be useful
it needs something that hasn't been
invented yet so yeah
that is it that's my thoughts sorry
there's more bugs in this video than
cyberpunk but really i think the point
is
when we're trying to discover like new
things to do with smartphones
and the more exciting they get the more
ways we discover are good
we're also finding the ways that aren't
so good and we can sort of
eliminate them or at least wait until
the tech is good enough
to like bring the idea back because like
i said this
version tends to like look the coolest i
kind of bugged for a second there but it
tends to look the coolest when it's
wrapping around on the outside
and that huawei mate x that we've all
been waiting for
that i've only really seen like in
professionals hands and in youtube
videos
that also seems like it would it would
look really cool but
i don't think it's the best way to do a
folding phone
and maybe you'll have other thoughts on
that but that's my experience and my
impressions
from using the flex pi 2. in the
meantime right now all this phone really
has in common
with a cicada is it's much louder
than you think it would be
anyway okay the bad jokes are over i
promise
i'm curious in the comments section if
you could let me know
which alternate form factor you are most
interested in
for me it's actually the rollables and i
haven't gotten to see one in person yet
but these new rollable phones that sort
of unfurl like a scroll they might have
the same
unprotected problem as this does
but they're also not trying to do a fold
flat and a hinge
they're more i don't know just different
i want to try one and see what that's
actually like to use
but also of course it's just more of
like variable aspect ratio so anyway i'm
curious what you guys think are you into
the swiveling are you into the clamshell
are you into the galaxy fold style
let me know we'll chat about it in the
comments section but yeah that's been it
just a quick thought
on this outside fold thanks for watching
and i'll catch you guys
very soon in the next one peace